- Sales, sales, sales, something
I don't talk about enough
and very much the foundation of my career.
Something I'm gonna
challenge myself in 2018
to talk more about.
This keynote's a little bit from 2016,
but I think your gonna enjoy it.
Here's the full episode so
for all you sales people,
tag up your sales homey in the comments
and enjoy, sit back, and listen.
(hip hop music)
(band music)
(audience applausing)
Whoo, it is dark.
Thank you so much for that warm welcome.
Excited about this.
I think, when I think about
making something happen
in the world, selling
something, getting a donation,
getting voted for.
Whatever the transaction is,
I always break down that world
into sales and marketing.
I think that I spend a
lot of time these days
in the marketing funnel
and really helping a lot
of my digital start ups and my
friends in digital marketing.
Oh, that you so much.
Good reaction to the darkness.
Jets jersey, that makes me super happy.
Trying to convince a lot
of people to go from sales
to understand the value of marketing.
I'll tell you right
now, through and through
when I pass away and they open me up,
I'm a salesman through and through.
I've been my whole life,
big ups to the sales people.
So coming to a sales conference
is a lot of fun for me
and I think there should be
more of them in our space
because I think the issue with
a lot of my marketing friends
and people is it's very up in the clouds
and it doesn't really
end up creating the thing
that I think we're all tied
to which is the transaction.
What is the KPI?
What are we actually trying to do?
I'm gonna give you a little
background of where I came from
for the people in here
that don't know my story
because I think it matters.
Then I want to talk about what I would do
if I was in this audience.
What I try to do as a salesman
is I try to reverse-engineer.
I try to figure out while on
stage who the audience is.
I try to figure out what
Simon and Seth and Arianna
and Frederick have already said,
'cause I know their spiels
really fuckin' well.
I'm trying to think about what
can I say that's different
that's gonna actually bring value.
The truth is, and I know
those four very well.
Frederick I think is a pure-bred salesman.
I really do think that
I was born very lucky
in that I think my
parents are very opposite.
I think I feel very
kinship with my marketing
and with my sales.
That's what I want to focus on
because I think a lot
of people here can make
a lot more money if they
eliminated two things:
one, laziness, to be very frank;
and two, idealistic points of view
of how they've made
their money in the past.
One of the biggest concerns I
have sitting here in a world
where I am hungry to get one
to two people, three people
to get a lot of value out of this talk
is the way you made your
money before is my enemy.
The way you've been successful
yesterday is my enemy.
It is stunning if you understood
what runs through my head
every morning on how little
I think anybody should give
a fuck about anything I
achieved yesterday back.
You're really only as
good as your last at bat.
The thing that I'm most passionate about,
I think many of you guys and
gals can agree with me on this,
is the landscape of sales
and all of communication
in our society has had a fundamental shift
over the last decade
because of technology.
There's just a lot of
people that are doing things
that are not bringing them
real value for their actions.
My religion in sales is attention.
Before I even think about how
to sell you my SAS product
'cause it's better than
the one that you're using,
or my wine, or why you should
us VaynerMedia and my agency,
or a new pair of sneakers,
or whatever you're selling
in this room.
Mid-market, enterprise,
small start up, the one thing
that connects us is the
end person's attention.
This is what I want to focus on at first.
My career of being
obsessed around attention
started when I was six,
and I'm not kidding.
This is an interesting story.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
I came here as a kid.
My dad eventually got a job as a stock boy
in a liquor store in New Jersey.
I originally lived in Queens
then I grew up in Edison, New Jersey.
In Edison, when I was
six and seven years old,
I tricked, manipulated, sold.
I sold my friends on the idea of standing
behind a lemonade stand all day.
So when I was six years old,
I had a six lemonade stand
franchise in Edison, New Jersey.
How many of you remember Big
Wheels, those little bikes?
I used to ride my Big
Wheels at the end of the day
every summer and pick up my cash
like I was little Tony
Soprano or something.
(audience laughing)
So I was a salesman early on.
It's funny, the reason my
friends were behind the register
selling the lemonade and I wasn't.
It wasn't 'cause I was fancy.
It wasn't because I didn't
want to do the work.
It's because, and this is me
now realizing this years later,
it was because I was
obsessed with attention.
While my homey's stood
behind the lemonade stands,
I walked up and down the streets.
By the way, for a lot of
the youngsters in here,
this was the 80s when
kids just went outside
and did random shit.
I would walk up and down the streets
and literally, this is how sick I am,
I would sit at the cross
sections of streets,
Tingley Lane in New Jersey,
Inman Avenue in New Jersey.
I would sit there and
I would watch people.
I would sit there for an hour.
I'm seven, six, seven eight years old.
I would it there for hours and
I would watch cars drive by
and I would try to see if
I could see their faces
and I could figure out which tree or pole
to put the lemonade stand sign on
because that would be the better one
because they would see
it and buy lemonade.
Early it was intuitive to
me at such a ridiculous age
that the number one
asset was the attention
and then what I had to
say is what mattered.
That the creative, the product,
the copy was the variable.
That the thing I said on
the other side of the phone
was the variable.
But before I could say it, no
matter how good my game was,
did I actually have their
attention or was I speaking
to somebody that wasn't paying attention.
I believe that the far
majority of this room
has become disconnected with the reality
of the end-consumer's attention.
We have taken for granted
whether through laziness,
not being compensated for it,
or whatever other variable.
You are not being good at what you do?
I don't know.
I believe that the market
of sales has lost its way.
I think it's the speed of attention shift
in today's society.
I went on to have a very
big baseball card business
when I was 12 and 13.
When I was 12, 13 I was
selling baseball cards
in the malls of New Jersey.
I was making two to 3,000 dollar a weekend
as a baseball card salesman.
I don't know about you
guys, but when you're 14
and you have $30,000
in cash under your bed,
and you're not selling weed,
you're a good fuckin' salesman.
So that was good.
By the way, I plan on
buying the New York Jets
which I think projected
by the time I'm ready
is gonna cost me between five
and eight billion dollars
and I'm convinced that when I
was 13 and had $30,000 in cash
it will be the richest I've ever been.
I just couldn't even begin
to think about spending
that kind of money.
When I was 14, my dad ruined my life,
dragged me into the liquor store,
paid me two bucks and hour to bag ice.
He now owned his own store
in Springfield, New Jersey.
I went from like being my own entrepreneur
and doing my thing to
working in this store
called Shoppers Discount
Liquors that I hated
because I bagged ice for 15 hours a day
and walked home with 30 bucks.
That was a bad--
That was two or three years of dark ages
of my professional career.
When I was 16, 17 I was allowed upstairs.
I realized people collected wine.
That was interesting to me
'cause I was into collecting
and I embarked in my career.
My career took an interesting turn
because I discovered the internet.
In 1997, I launched one of
the first E-commerce wine
businesses in America
called Wine Library dot Com.
I grew my dad's business
from a three to a 60 million
dollar business in five years.
I did it through sales and marketing.
I did it in two ways.
One, I was out marketing everybody
by buying Google Adwords,
by doing email.
How many people here do email marketing?
Raise your hands.
In 1997, I had a 200,000 person
email database selling wine
that had 91.3% open rates.
Right, yeah.
Now, it wasn't 'cause I was such a hero.
That same list now is like 31.3,
it's because nobody was doing it.
The thing that I want
to talk to you about is
the stunning excuses that
my salesmen friends make up
for not doing SnapChat,
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram,
or LinkedIn content.
I love my sales friends who
are like, "I do LinkedIn."
I'm like, no, no, no.
You don't do LinkedIn.
You sit there and you
fuckin' try to connect people
and you're a fuckin'
spambot you motherfucker.
(audience laughing)
Not a saleman.
Fuck.
Anyway, sorry.
(audience laughing)
Truth, truth, like I do LinkedIn sales.
No you don't you just click buttons
and you hope and pray and
you control copy and paste
the same fuckin' message to every person
'cause you're fuckin' lazy.
So, anyway...
Real estate, when there's
a new vacation destination
or new town or Hudson Yards
is being built right here,
the people that buy first,
if they're right, win.
You don't get the beachfront
property by waiting four years
for what's the value of it.
I believe that a purebred
salesperson is never crippled
if her or his actions are not fruitful.
I believe a purebred
salesperson understands that
that's part of the game,
that's part of the hustle.
There's so much upside
by doing a new tactic,
even if you hit it once
out of every nine times,
the overall ROI of all those hours
becomes a net positive score.
That is why I think I've been successful.
My career in sales has be
predicated by not being crippled
by overworking to learn
something new, period.
It is insanity.
Let me use that word aggressively.
It is insanity for you to disrespect
all the social media platforms
and what they can mean
for sales for you.
You have to understand, if one person
executes transactions
through it, then you can too.
The problem is, it's hard.
The problem is, it takes time.
The problem is, there's a lot
of easier ways to do it today
but those things go away.
Anybody here that's been
doing email sales for 15 years
knows what I'm about to say
which was 10 and 15 years ago
it worked better.
Right?
Because we play in one
game, my friends, all of us.
You're trying to reach that
person on the other end,
we play in the B to B
arbitrage of attention.
It's just supply and demand.
How many people, by a show of hands,
this is actually interesting.
Let's start with this.
Let's establish that lying is the devil.
I have no interest in your head nods.
I want full fuckin' hands.
Here we go.
How many people here, now,
in 2016, actually hate it
when another person, another
human being calls them.
Raise your hand.
Raise it high.
I want you to look around.
Look around.
Raise it higher, just real high please.
These are human beings,
our fellow human beings,
who actually hate when another
human being calls them.
Let me tell you why and
then let me tell you
why it's important for this conversation.
The reason they hate it
is because time has become
the number one asset to
every person in this room.
The emerging pillar in our society
besides the health and wellness
of our family and money,
the number one emerging pillar of value
to everybody in this room and
everybody in this conference
and everybody outside is time.
Calling somebody when
they weren't expecting it
has now become stealing one's time.
Because we have alternative
of when that person calls
you can say, just text me, just email me.
I will call you back on my time.
It is my belief that when
I audit the sales ecosystem
and all the start-ups I'm involved with
and all the businesses I'm involved with
that sales people steal their clients time
for their vested interests
instead of reverse
engineering the value
of that person's time.
It is in our best vested
interest to send that email.
interest to make that phone call.
We are not reverse engineering the fact
that these people have become busy.
Now, another thing that's
extremely fascinating for me
being in this room, I grew
up in B to C my whole life.
Only seven years ago, when
I started VaynerMedia,
did I go into the B to B world.
Just for the people that don't know here,
I have a 650 person social-digital agency
that I've grown the last four years
from a three to a 100 million
dollar business in sales,
not fuckin' valuation.
By the way, that's another conversation
for another fuckin' day.
I think the thing that will be interesting
to a lot of people here is I've done
that mainly on not selling.
Like we don't really do RFPs.
I'm not interested in
selling somebody who--
I would tell my number--
If somebody said what's your
most religious sales tactic,
it is not to try to sell to
somebody who is unsellable.
I think one of the most fascinating things
that I've audit when I
look at the sales ecosystem
is how much people take time trying
to convert somebody who's unconvertible.
Yes, your product may
be 8,000 times better,
but if that boss's boss
is best friend homies
with the alternative legacy
software, you fuckin' lost.
Then I watch people think
that they're gonna convert it on merit.
There's no fuckin' merit.
There's just human beings
making human decisions.
I think that we need to get a
lot less romantic about that
and start being much more
practical about the ecosystem.
Let me tell you another way
that I've grown that business
that I think of instead of pontificating
and cursing up here, let
me give you direct tactic
that I think a lot of you guys can use.
Couple books ago, 'cause I decided
to write those kind of things,
I wrote a book called
"The Thank You Economy".
Super interesting to me.
It's the notion of if you
provide so much up front value
to an individual, can
he actually guilt them
into buying shit.
Especially if all your
actions are predicated
on not expecting them to buy it.
That's the big part.
When the energy of your
tactics is to convert,
you will lose.
When your energy is to
disproportionately bring value
and let the chips fall where
they may, you will win.
It will change your behavior.
It will change the
energy of the execution.
Let me give you a story.
VaynerMedia, there was a
certain CMO that I really wanted
to get to because I really
wanted their business.
I don't like doing RFPs
because it's a crapshoot
and we're not very good at them, right.
I have the fortunate
nature of having a brand
so a lot of business comes
to me, but this one wasn't
and I wanted it.
So I decided to follow--
And this is my number one tactic
for every person in this
room that I am positive
that if you actually put
in the work and do it,
that you will email me--
This is really the reason I'm giving this
is 'cause I want you to
email me in four months
and be like, "Hey man,
I saw you in New York
"at the Sales Machine Conference.
"I thought you were a
little bit ridiculous,
"but I did this thing
and it actually worked.
"Cool, thanks."
That's it, that's what I want.
And here's the tactic.
How many people here are in B to B sales?
Raise your hand.
Awesome.
Coming from B to C and now being in B to B
and being part of companies
like Budding Medium,
Perculated, and Wildfire
that we've had successful
exits in and watching
the landscape of sales
in that environment.
I've done very well with
my B to B investments.
I am stunned how much easier
it is to be a B to B salesman
then a B to C salesman.
You literally know the
name of the fuckin' person
you're selling to.
This is a big deal.
It's a big deal because by
knowing the name in 2016,
you have the opportunity to
use big data in your advantage
on a micro-level to create
the world that you want.
Let me explain.
I found the CMO that I wanted on Twitter.
Some of the people that
you're trying to get to
won't be on Twitter.
They may be on LinkedIn.
They may be on Facebook.
They may be on Instagram.
But the fun part is 60-70%
of your prospects are on
one of these platforms and
putting out data publicly
on what they like and what they're in to.
I followed this individual and I noticed
that he was a humongous St.
Louis Cardinals baseball fan.
This is when my plan went into action.
I started watching everything
he was tweeting about.
Ironically, I'm like a cobra in the grass.
I'll tell you the number one thing
that really separates good salespeople
from bad salespeople is patience.
I'm patient as fuck.
So I was staying in the
grass, just waiting.
Collecting content, being patient,
really mapping what he's
into, paying attention.
Ironically, it coincided with
my fantasy baseball league.
So I'm in my fantasy baseball draft.
I've got the team I want.
I've got a couple of empty
slots on the reserve thing.
I'm like, "You know what?
"I'm gonna draft this up-and-coming
rookie Cardinals player
"for maybe other reasons
"than just winning my
fantasy baseball team."
So I drafted--
Any Cardinals fans in here?
Any couple, maybe two or three.
I drafted a guy by the
name of Kolten Wong,
infielder for the St. Louis Cardinals
before he was even in
major league baseball.
So then I wait.
And I wait for Kolten Wong to
get up to the major leagues.
And I wait for Kolten
Wong to do something good.
And then I see what I needed to,
him Tweeting about Kolten Wong
which allowed me to jump
into that tweet and say,
"Hey, I have Kolten
Wong on my fantasy team.
"Isn't he awesome."
He replied, "Yeah, he's awesome."
That's it.
Patience, remember.
Don't close on the first date.
So we interact a little bit more
about the Cardinals, they're
making their playoff run.
Somewhere about three weeks
later, he tweets me back
and says, "Hey, I seen that you're a CEO
"of a digital agency.
"We're thinking about maybe changing up
"our roster a little bit.
"Is this something we could talk about?"
We sure fuckin' can.
(audience laughing)
I want to give you real data here.
Less than an hour of work,
being patient spread off of
probably about four months,
I was able to convert that strategy
into a 3.6 million dollar paying client.
Right?
Sales, sales, but sales not that look like
here's a blank email that I'm gonna blast.
Everybody's obsessed with scalability.
Everybody is obsessed with scalability
and all the action in sales
is scaling the unscalable.
I believe that sales, even
in today's environment,
is still a very (spitting)
face-to-face game.
Right?
I think a lot of us agree with that.
I think the biggest
disconnect from the people
that just heard that in this room,
that have done that their whole lives,
they were like, "Yeah, hell yeah."
Is that they don't realize
that technology is now
the scalable gateway drug
to the human interactions.
I sell--
I'm going to Cleveland
right now after this.
There's a basketball game I want to see.
I'm gonna sell on that
plane on the way there
because I'm using technology,
Twitter, Facebook, LinkedIn,
and these platforms as a gateway drug
to create an interpersonal relationship.
There are people I know very well
that I've spent very little
time with in real life,
but I do that through those channels
and then when we see each other
there's a total different feeling I have
for these three individuals.
These are people I could never
even have a relationship with
without this technology.
These are people that I
haven't even met more than once
that I feel enormous kinship towards them,
and the dude with the Jets jersey,
because I've put in the sales work.
Why do you go golfing with a client?
Why do you eat a fuckin'
steak with a client?
Why do you go to networking events?
You do it to create context at scale.
You do it to create context.
The absolute closer and
the enabler and the jabbing
and the flirter, that
essence of energy is context.
If you know that girl's boyfriend.
If you know their
interest in the Cardinals.
You have a leg up on the competition.
It's why you spend time with your clients
and the decision makers
and the influencers
of the decision makers because
you are building context.
What technology today does and
these five or six platforms
that are the current
state of social media do
all at the finger tip of your phone
when you're going to take a
piss or flying to Cleveland
or whatever you want.
Ultimately scalable, you
can do it at any time,
six p.m., one a.m., whatever
you want, however you roll.
You get up early, you get up late.
You can hustle in these
platforms and create context.
The fact of the matter
is, almost nobody does it.
Nobody does it because they lack patience.
They short--
You know how many of you in
this room have a point of view
on what Facebook or LinkedIn or Twitter
can do for your business
and you've never used the fuckin' product?
It's real, thanks for that one clap.
I liked it.
(audience laughing)
So we live in 2016 in a world
where the majority of you,
when you live like a normal human being
and don't put on your
sales outfit for the day,
would never convert on the actions
that you take as a sales
person during the work day.
The amount of you that
delete every fucking email
that you get that is a bulk email.
The amount of you that will
never answer that phone.
The amount of you that nev--
Who here is super fired up to go home
and go through their
direct mail carefully?
I'm fascinated by the
disconnect of who you are
as a human being and how you act
when it's in your vested
financial interest
for another human being
to act the way you want
because it's more convenient for you.
That is the arbitrage.
And that will always be
the arbitrage forever.
So many of you have done business
because of word of mouth.
Right?
How many people here
have landed more business
because of word-of-mouth
from a prior transaction?
Raise your hands.
If you didn't raise your hand,
you just don't fuckin'
understand it or your lazy
and that's fuckin' interesting too.
(audience laughing)
When I think about social
media, all I think about it
as the plumbing of
word-of-mouth in our society.
I'm fascinated by how much business I do
with somebody after I actually sell them
and what I do with them to
create that word of mouth
versus what I did to get
them in the first place.
The enormous amount of
energy that we all deploy
as salespeople to get the business
versus what we do with that business.
Even if it's hand it off
to an account person.
If you were that point of reference,
you're ability to stay in
that ecosystem and bring value
is incredible.
Again, I implore you
to understand the value
of public data.
Let me give you a B to C scenario,
but you can deploy this in your own world.
Wine Library, before "Thank You Economy",
I wanted an example for my keynotes
about how I was doing
the "Thank You Economy".
I was very passionate about
having somebody buy something
on Wine Library that was inexpensive
and then overwhelming them with a gift
based on their big data.
I love sports, so no question
this is another sports story.
Guy buys a case of Pinot Grigio for $111.
We made 17 bucks in profit on the case.
We had to find people with unusual names
because we had to find them on Twitter
and this was still 2011.
So finally we found one.
They were having a tough time
finding people on Twitter
that were buying wine for the first time.
I wanted a first time customer.
Guy buys a case of
Pinot Grigio in Chicago.
We made 11 bucks.
They find him.
He has an unusual name
like Vaynerchuk, you know.
We find him, it's definitely him.
We look and we find his Twitter.
His whole Twitter stream
is about J Cutler,
the quarterback of the Chicago Bears.
Just tons of J Cutler.
I love you, J Cutler this, da, da, da.
Great.
I tell the Thank You department
which is something we have at Wine Library
which is not customer
service, it's offense.
Customer service is defense.
The Thank You department kicks in
and we go and buy him a $350
jersey signed by J Cutler
and we send it to him.
ROI negative on that transaction,
I think we can all agree.
So now I'm pumped.
We finally found somebody, we sent it.
You know my keynotes are coming up.
I'm gonna have a great case study.
He's gonna buy a lot of wine.
He's gonna do something.
It's gonna be unbelievable.
I can't wait to tell all of you.
Three weeks go by, mother
fucker didn't get back to us.
I'm like, "What the fuck?"
Ungrateful asshole! (laughing)
Nothing.
I'm like calling four times a day.
I'm like, "Your sure, I know it's in spam.
"Get the I.T. department,
this is impossible."
Nothing.
I'm boarding a plane to
Orlando, I get a phone call.
"Gary."
I'm like, "Yeah."
They're like, "We got something."
I'm like, "Finally, what did he do?"
"Better."
"Okay, better?"
They're like, "Listen to this."
I'm like, "Okay?"
"We just got an order from
Plano, Texas for $6,000
"worth of red burgundy."
I'm like, "Great."
"Now, that's great, but wait 'til you hear
"the note in the order."
I'm like, "Cool."
"Dear Wine Library, first of
all, what a great red burgundy
"selection you have.
"Make sure you don't
ship this, it's hot here.
"Hold it for awhile.
"Ship it when it's cooler."
Next, "P.S. You sent my friend, John,
"a Bears jersey the other day
"when he bought some wine from you.
"P.S.S. I'm a huge Bruce Springsteen fan."
(audience laughing)
For very little money and
for a solid amount of effort
you could go home from this conference
and go through your entire
Rolodex of everybody
that you sold something
to in the last year.
Go on social media, look at their data,
and do something that shows effort.
Let me tell you what's not effort.
The at scale, hand written
note, that wasn't hand written,
it was just a tactic to fake effort.
What about actual effort?
What about actually sending
me something about the Jets,
or root beer, or Lionel Richie
because it's very easy to figure out
I like those three things.
What people are underestimating is
the word-of-mouth ecosystem
that we actually live in
because this thing has
changed our behavior.
I don't know if you've noticed,
but we now have all defaulted
into this amazing notion
that we should tell the world
everything about everything,
always about everything.
It's what we do.
For some reason, everybody
needs to know our two cents
on the game last night, on
where the world's going.
This is what we do.
We share now.
You may not like it, it's the
reality of the marketplace.
One thing that people
share more than anything
is when they are caught
off-guard or that they can feel
that somebody gave them
more effort than the market.
My belief is that the
greatest version of a person
in the world is a purebred sales person.
Let me tell you why.
My definition, one man's definition,
of a purebred salesperson
is one that is obsessed
with providing more
value to the other person
than they ask for in return.
When you make that mental shift,
and more importantly, when your
actions start speaking that,
things start to massively unlock.
I have built both of my
very large businesses
on one backbone, which is I want to know
what this person's
gonna say at my funeral.
I have no interest in selling
in something I don't believe.
I know for fact that there's
a staggering percentage
of people here as they
become educated in the market
they sell in that they
actually do not believe
that their product is the best.
I could not function in that environment.
I'm not judging you.
We all have our different
paths and different things,
loans, mortgages, respect.
Not trying to go there.
But I would tell you that
when you fully believe
in what you sell, through and through,
it gets a hell of a lot easier.
When you actually give a fuck
about the other person more than you,
it gets triple easy my friends.
So, I implore all of you to understand
that we're living
through a marketplace now
where our consumers have
more information than ever.
You're not gonna win a deal
on inefficiency of
information of our consumer.
I implore you to start
producing two things.
One, leading with the heart
and reverse engineering
what your end consumer,
whether they bought from you
or they're your prospect.
What makes them tick above and beyond
being the decision maker
of your fuckin' product.
And number two, start
thinking about the people
you've sold to after you sold to them
and understand what they
can mean to your business
by you actually caring about them as well
because they're still valuable to you
even though you hooked up.
Got it?
Cool.
I'd like to spend the rest
of my time very honestly
with you on Q&A.
I know that the mics are back there,
so if you guys can start
lining up, I'll wait for people
to get back there.
Please don't be shy.
This is why I don't like
the mics that stand.
I like to move it around.
I find people are lazy and don't just want
to walk back there, but please go there.
I'd love to get far more detailed.
Those are my fundamental
principles on sales.
I think it's stunning how many
people have not recognized
that technology doesn't
replace the way we all sold.
Technology is enabling the
scale of how we old sold.
I think that's probably--
If you ask me what I wanted
to leave with more than
anything, it's that.
I'm, I fly all around the
country to close my deals.
I want to be in the goddamn room.
I don't even like Skype.
I lose the context.
I need to feel the energy.
The amount of work that I do
to get on third and a half base
through Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram is remarkable.
The context I have on the
levers that I need to pull
in that room, shit's sold
before I fucking got there.
You like that?
Thanks.
(audience laughing)
That was a good way to end.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Alright, the good part.
What's your name, my man?
- My name's Shawn.
Can you hear me?
- [Gary] Clearly.
- Well you inspired me
to leave my corporate job
to create my own business
because according to you I'm 25.
I'd be fuckin' stupid to
stay at my corporate job.
- [Gary] I believe that.
- So I followed what you said.
- [Gary] Do you have the
chops to pull it off?
- Well I've been doin' it a year
and I've been making more
money working for myself,
taking Tuesday off, and
working on a Saturday
because I took the risk.
- [Gary] Mazeltov!
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- But Jill Reiley turned me on too.
She's standing right over there.
- [Gary] I see, I see.
- So I got to give her the credit.
- [Gary] Are you willing to
kick her a little commission?
- Everything's negotiable.
She made me read one of your
books before I worked for her.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- Right now, I help sales
and marketing work together
and one of the things is
sales managers they want KPIs,
- [Gary] Yes.
- Like calls, touches,
that don't make sense.
- [Gary] Yes.
- One thing I advocate for,
like with social selling,
is use LinkedIn touches,
okay, instead of call metrics.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And they're against it.
What you're talking about is
even pushing that further.
Right.
Using LinkedIn, Twitter, other tools,
but corporate sales people
and even marketing managers
and directors, VPs.
They don't want to go that way.
They still want 150 calls a day.
So how do you incentivize them or say,
hey you got to abandon all the KPIs, allow
people to use LinkedIn.
- There's only one way.
The CEO of that company has
to change the incentives.
Let me tell you how quickly you
can get a sales force to do.
Every single thing that
is wrong at VaynerMedia is
one billion percent my fault.
Right?
It's run from the top.
You can get a sales force to get involved
in social tomorrow, make
the KPIs around that.
If you actually incentivize
the behavior, they will do it.
One thing I love about
us, me being a salesman,
is though we're fuckin' easy.
We are reverse engineering how we get
our fuckin' bonuses and our money.
We are blindly--
If tomorrow your company said
if you send out a thousand
Tweets that are not automated, by hand,
and that's how you make your bonus,
you're sending a thousand
tweets not by hand
and that's how you're
making your fuckin' bonus.
So the answer to your question, my man,
is it's not in the middle,
it's not in the upper middle,
it's the gal and the guy at the top
that has to change all the rules
to the behavior of the sales organization
and it happens really fuckin' quick.
I'll tell you, this is
gonna throw you for a loop,
I have forced some of my start-ups
to add more calling in
as a KPI 'cause they want
to go completely automated and technology
and they disrespect the phone.
Do I think the phone is
losing in conversion?
Yes I do.
I think it's behavior in the market.
Do I think it's zero?
Absolutely not.
Do I think it's silly
to just have one move?
Yes I do.
- [Shawn] Awesome, thank you so much.
- Thank you brother, thank you.
My man over here.
- Hi Gary.
- [Gary] How are you man?
- Great man.
Big fan of your SnapChat channel.
- [Gary] Thank you brother.
- I watch all the time.
- Thank you man.
- So I'm from Gainesville, Florida.
Big tech scene there.
- [Gary] Yep.
- John Spence, speaker,
he's from there too.
- [Gary] Yep.
- He'll attest to it.
I like using business as a force for good.
That's like what I've
been doing my entire life.
Here's the thing that we're doing now.
We do microfinance loans
- Okay.
for needy entrepreneurs
- Yes
in East Africa
- Okay
through cultural tourisms
and we do it at zero percent interest.
- [Gary] I love it.
- So that's taken off as number one two
in Tripadvisor dot com and
Lonely Planet Guidebook now.
- [Gary] Yep.
- So we're getting all the tourists.
The other thing we do, we have a site
called Saganet dot org.
- Okay.
We do e-mentoring for
K through 12 students
to get them interested in STEM fields
- [Gary] Yes.
- by partnering them with--
partnering students, teachers,
classrooms, and families
with NASA scientist or other
career scientists virtually
around the world.
- [Gary] Okay.
- That's taken off and that's partnership
with the Carl Sagan
Foundation as well (mumbling).
So here's my new business
idea and I want your blessing
or your criticism on it.
So I just acquired my dream house.
- [Gary] You did.
- Right before coming here.
I was in Montreal, flew down
to Gainesville, Florida,
signed a piece of paper,
and flew right back up here
to see you actually.
- Amazing.
- [Gary] Thank you, congratulations.
- Thanks to John.
Thank you.
It's a beautiful Victorian from 1903.
I'm gonna turn into
- 1903 is a great year.
It is, was, right?
(audience laughing)
If you have some wine from 1903,
I'd love to stock it in there.
- I wish.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna turn it
into a boutique hotel.
10,000 per night to stay there
and it's going to be a
donation to my 501(c)3.
Everything gets donated in,
your fee for staying there
becomes 100% donated to
a 501(c)3 tax write off
and then I use it entirely, I
don't take any salary from it,
to do good in the world.
- [Gary] Okay.
- On top of that, we have, I have buddies
that have car rental
companies for exotic cars.
I have other friends that
have jet leasing companies.
What we're gonna do is
bizspoke sort of system
where we're gonna have the
billion dollar package.
For one billion dollars,
watch for this on Indiegogo.
For one billion dollars you
can buy a room in the house
and you can give it to
your kin and for that
we'll fly you from wherever you
are in the world to us for--
And then we'll show you what
we're doing with your money.
And then we'll take you anywhere
in the world you want to go
to see it in action.
Then we'll bring you
also back to Gainesville
and we'll put you in touch
with thought leaders,
scientists, anything that can
make this happen in the world
and make that happen.
Again, it's a billion dollar
donation to a 501(c)3.
- Anybody who doesn't think
that cool, is being silly.
I love it.
- [Man] Sweet, so that's a blessing?
- Cool, it's a blessing and I'll take a--
When the Ranger's schedule comes out,
this is in Montreal right?
- [Man] Oh no, this gonna
be in Gainesville, Florida.
I'm from Montreal originally
- Oh, the house is in Florida?
So go haves, this is in Gainesville.
- Got it.
Well I don't want to go there,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I'll also take a night
in the $10,000 hotel.
Cheers, cool man.
Yes dear.
- [Brown haired Woman] Hi
- Hey.
- Thank you for the talk, Gary.
I have a question.
Just like you and Beyonce, we
all have 24 hours in a day.
Knowing that time is valuable
and if you do your due
diligence with clients
how do you, with your inbound leads,
vet and qualify them
to know how you can get
killer clients on your roster.
I own a digital marketing agency.
- [Gary] Intuitively.
- Yeah, my other question
in case you answered
that really quick.
Can you tell us a story if
you did your due diligence
and you sent the $350 jersey and all that
and you get to the very end
and then you lost business?
Or a big client--
- [Gary] Like lost as
a in we didn't get it?
- You closed and lost
and then any business
that you--
- [Gary] Closed, had it, and then lost it?
- You pitched it and you got really far
and then it was a close loss.
- [Gary] Happens all the time.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Just fundamentally
not crippled by it.
Like I've never thought
- Just moved to the end
about that in my entire life.
I think the biggest reason people lose
is they spend all their fuckin'
time thinking about that
and I don't give a fuck.
- [Brown-Haired Woman] Perfect.
- I mean it's the truth, by the way.
On a very serious gig and I think
a lot of you are getting it.
Dwelling on a loss,
microanalyzing why it happened,
it happened because of
750,000 different random
shit things that you
couldn't of controlled
or because you fucked up.
Neither one of them's really
that valuable to think about.
I'm just on to the next one.
- [Brown-Haired Woman] Thanks.
- You're welcome.
It's true.
Again, there's some
things that I believe in,
like in purebred sales and
purebred entrepreneurship
that have clearly gone awry
in the last half decade
to a decade.
If you're a sales person,
and you guys all know this,
this is why you're here.
I mean if you're here, you're
not scared of the loss.
You're not crippled by the loss.
Now, some of you are more
crippled than others.
I think the most successful of the bunch
are just literally unphased.
It's insane to me how I was scared
that I was gonna have
to recall one for you.
That's how little I remember them.
And they happen every fucking month.
We lose pitches all the time.
I'm like they're just
stupid fuckin' people
'cause we're the best.
(audience laughing)
That's what I think.
- Hi Gary.
- Hey man.
My name is Steven Wolkins
and thanks for the talk.
I can relate to you in
a lot of ways just being
because I came from a B to C world
and now I'm in a B to B world.
There's a lot of different things
and I think a lot of the
themes that we've talked about
in this conference as a whole
and one of the things
you brought up is just
kind of caring about that other person
on the other side of the table.
Right?
One of the things I keep
trying to think about
is how do we teach that
to other people as well
because I genuinely am
interested in people.
I genuinely love to help people
and that's kind of my philosophy on sales.
But we're all incentivized on that dollar.
Like how we make our own
money which is necessary
and I completely get that.
- As we should be.
But how do you then teach someone empathy
and actually caring,
genuinely asking how are you
and actually caring what the answer is.
- [Gary] I don't know other
than telling every sales person
in this room go reverse engineer
the 500 best sales people
you've every heard of or know.
Everyone of them has
the same fuckin' shtick
which is they play a
marathon instead of a sprint,
they deploy empathy and gratitude,
they're more patient.
I don't know how to teach those things.
When it's so in everybody's face.
It is so in everybody's
face, it's just hard.
It's hard to be patient because
you want a new fuckin' watch.
It's just real.
I don't know and very
honest with you, I do it.
I put out content and scale
but I really don't give
a fuck if any of you
take it an go use it.
I really don't.
I can't come to your
house and make you do it.
By the way, it's called
meritocracy and capitalism.
The people that do it win
and the ones that still think
that there's some fuckin'
short-term system that they're
gonna be the one person
that's gonna figure it
out and crush in sales,
they don't win as much.
As it should be.
Cool.
(audience applauding)
- [Red Shirt Man] Hey
Gary, is D-Rock here?
- D-Rock is here.
He's right there.
- D-Rock, you're the man.
- Stand up D-Rock.
(audience cheering)
The little plug for D-Rock is
he's been shootin' Gary live
unto they call Daily V.
It's super bad ass.
- I appreciate it brother,
let's talk about it.
We talked about sales today.
I believe in marketing and branding.
I put out a daily Vlog
two-three times a week
that follows me around.
It shows the stories of
being an entrepreneur.
People watch it.
They like it.
And then they want to do business with me.
It's not super complicated like.
So if you put out content.
It's one thing to do surprise and delight,
the Jets jersey and things of that nature.
What about if you actually put out videos
or audios or written
articles about your stories
and how you were a good sales
person or your best things.
How do you bring value?
I bring value to people in my ecosystem.
I want zero in return because
I know the network effect
creates the return.
- I run a D.J. entertainment agency.
We do events all over the city
and also digital marketing consulting.
You inspire me to actually
film kind of a day in the life.
I just shot it on Sunday.
- Love it.
I like to think I live a very interesting
life worth sharing.
- [Gary] I think, just so you
know, I think reality T.V.
and voyeurism and human
behavior proves we all do.
Everybody, the whole 15
minutes of fame thing
is now that everybody's
famous to 15 people.
The market's gonna decide
how interesting you are.
You're gonna be interesting
to a million people or 74.
But it's clearly got an opportunity.
- [D.J.] It sounds like you answered it
before I even asked the question.
- That's what I like to do.
- [D.J.] Pretty much--
- Times invaluable.
- [D.J.] What advice
would you give to somebody
that really hasn't created
a lot of video content,
has some following online--
- Just live it.
Nobody wants anything that's manipulated.
Just do you.
You may think it's interesting.
I may not.
It doesn't matter.
The easiest thing to do is to be yourself,
it's also the hardest thing to do.
Right?
So I would tell you as
somebody who loses--
You know how I've lost business?
I cursed at a board meeting
and somebody was very conservative
and said, "Let's not give
business to that fuck face."
(audience laughing)
Right?
But that's okay because I win net-net.
I will tell you that it's really--
The one thing I can't do is not be myself.
It's been the thing that is absolutely
separated me from the pack.
- [D.J.] Awesome, thank you.
- You got it.
I'm gonna sneak one more in.
Let's do it.
Last question, I'm so sorry.
They're like buzzing me here.
Go ahead, darlin'.
But you hit me up on Twitter.
I promise I'll answer it.
- Hi Gary.
I work for a nonprofit
and I know you've done
a lot of work with nonprofits as well.
We rely tremendously on volunteers
and we're trying to monetize
with that volunteering.
We're showing companies
there's a value to that.
Translate to charitable contributions.
How do we honor, do you have
any ideas of how we can honor
that contribution of volunteering
but also surprise and delight
those potential customers.
Essentially these corporations
that have these charitable
contributions to give in
a way that makes sense
for a nonprofit.
- [Gary] I want to make sure
I'm following this right.
Give me a little bit more context.
Like go a little more detail.
What do you guys do?
- Sure, we sell opportunities
for employee engagement.
So team building, volunteering,
but a lot of companies
they say, "Well we're
already giving our time.
"Why do you also want to have
a charitable contribution?"
Whereas the reality is there's a cost
to running these events
and there's also a value
to these companies.
- [Gary] I see and what
those employees are doing
is actually something charitable?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Right, so you're not
taking them to softball games.
That group is team building around
doing something charitable.
- Exactly.
So the organization almost thinks
you're almost double dipping.
- Yes.
Yes.
Challenging for sure.
I think, as I think about that,
I reverse engineer, I think
one of the things you need
to think a whole lot about
is the ROI of a cohesive
unit and retention.
Something I'm very passionate about is
emotional intelligence versus IQ, right.
I think one thing to really--
Businesses are funny, they like money.
So the first place I would
go is to run a report
or analyze what actually
happens to the retention
of their employees if
they actually do this.
If you told me as the CEO of VaynerMedia
that if on top of giving you my people
during their work hours to build a home,
that I have to give you $10,000
but you're gonna save me $27,000
because 2.7 of my employees are gonna stay
for a year longer and I'm not gonna have
to spend money on recruiting
and replacement costs.
Because when that's the ethos, go there.
The biggest problem is people get too--
The reason I've been successful
on the boards and NGO
and you know of my work is
because I've brought business DNA
to the nonprofit sector.
Let's eliminate the romance.
Don't tell me the fluff.
Tell me that I'm gonna save $17,000 a year
by giving you $25,000 and
I'll write you $50,000.
Got it?
- [Nonprofit Woman] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(audience cheering)
Thank you guys.
I'm sorry Bro, I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Bye guys.
Sales people leave your two
cents on what you just heard.
Will love to get your comments.
Let me know.
(hip hop music)